this is the Jocko underground podcast
it's number 46 Echo Charles is here with
me I got something for you to kick this
off today I want to talk to you about
something a little quote the quote is
there are no Solutions only trade-offs
you try to get the best trade-off you
can get that's all you can hope for that
is a quote from Thomas Sowell famous
economist
he's written he's written like 89 bucks
or something I'm actually just ordering
them all
because that that guy the points he
makes are phenomenal the fir the book
that I kind of is one of my favorite
books is called basic economics we I've
raised it at certain points on the
podcast haven't ever covered the thing
in full but anyways
Thomas Soul if you don't know who he is
go look him up he's freaking awesome but
there's no Solutions only trade-offs and
and this is certainly a good
it's a good way of thinking that a lot
of people don't really
a lot of people don't really understand
it right you got to recognize that
you're not always going to get what you
want
you're only going to get
some of what you want and even to get
some of what you want you're gonna have
to give up something else that's the way
it works and people don't want to admit
that
and when I heard this from Thomas soul
the first time I heard I didn't hear it
from Thomas so at all I was I was trying
to buy my first house
and I was looking at various properties
you know I had the real estate agent you
know giving me the looks showing me and
I was being kind of finicky
you know like wow I don't know about
that and finally my real estate agent
who got frustrated with me because
probably because I shot down a couple
deals where I was like yeah yeah not
really finally my real estate agent says
um
every house is going to have advantages
and disadvantages every house every
single house that you want it's going to
have a big yard but it's gonna be a
small house or it's gonna be a small
house but it's gonna have a big yard or
it's gonna have a low price but it needs
work or it's going to be in good shape
but it's gonna have a high price or it's
gonna have a bad layout that's flexible
or it's going to have a good layout but
there's not much flexibility to it or
it's going to have hey a bunch of
privacy but it's hard to get to or it's
going to be easy to get to but you don't
have a lot of privacy so the list goes
on and on and
and a lot of times it's just the price
versus whatever you know oh you can live
in this neighborhood but it costs more
or you can have a bigger house but it
costs more sometimes that's the that's
the
that's the variable
but here's why I wanted to bring this up
it's real obvious but sometimes
we fail to recognize what the trade-offs
are and that we can actually parse them
out and figure out what part of the deal
you want to keep what what is actually
important to you
so that you can keep the things that you
care about and you can let go of the
things
that you don't really care about
so when you're putting a deal together
you got to think about this
but here's the thing
this is the important part this is your
life too
right this is actually your life too you
don't get to do everything you want to
do you don't nobody does
you don't get too
spend time with your family and focus on
work and focus on training and focus on
learning and focus on relaxing and
learning a new skill like you don't get
to focus on everything
it doesn't work that way
we have to pay attention to it though
and then fundamentally what it boils
down to is you need to prioritize and
execute but
with the time that you have in your life
that you want to focus you gotta weigh
out
and parse out what's actually really
important to you so you can get the best
let's say the best deal out of life you
have to you have to understand
what's on the table
you got to understand what's on the
table and I think that's what the
mistake people people don't even know
what's on the table they don't they
don't pay attention to what's on the
table like they don't pay attention to
what the trade-offs are they don't pay
attention to what they care about or
what they don't care about and sometimes
they care about something that somebody
else cares about and they're thinking
that now that's important
or they just see what's real obvious and
they just grab whatever they can without
thinking about what they're going to
leave on the table you know you're gonna
you can only fit so much in your hands
and some of it's going to left get left
behind
so you got to think about that
you got to pay attention to that
because if you're not paying attention
to it you're going to leave some things
on the table
and you're going to look up
and you won't be able to hold anything
else
so pay attention
probably a good situation to detach take
a step back how do you do that write
down what's on the table actually write
it down that's how you detach from it
you write it down you make a list of
what's on the table you make a list of
what's at stake you make a list of what
the trade-offs are and then you
prioritize that list to make sure that
the trade-offs because there's no
solution there's no perfect solution
you're only going to get trade-offs so
pay attention so that you're trading off
the right things so you can keep as much
of what you want as you can and you can
let go the things that you don't care
about
little life advice from Thomas Sowell
Woody I remember a long time ago I did
this interview with this um it was like
a magazine but you got interviewed yeah
and it was like and they're talking
about work work balance or work life
work balance yeah like how do you do and
maybe the guy I thought I was more busy
than I really was but
yeah but I do I but that did make me
think though it made me think like wait
a second yeah like I do
kind of
like I don't stress like oh I'm not
paying enough attention to this without
it but then so and my answer ended up
being I only care like about four things
really like I don't care about like my
fashion or you know how like some people
you can see they care about and I'm not
knocking fashion I'm just saying but
some people don't care about it myself
included yeah exactly right and I
wouldn't even say I don't care about
understand I care very little about it
I'm not over here like staying up at
night stressing about I need to spend
more time on my fashion but um but
there's like four things I cared about
and it was like you know my family my
work like like health and fitness and
then like Jiu Jitsu or something that's
kind of it really you know it's a good
list right there right I mean what else
is there really I mean so anyway my
question is like do you like what do you
care about you think like what's your I
mean it's the same stuff but here's the
thing
you're not gonna get all you can't get
you can't give a hundred percent to your
family can yeah and you can't give 100
to your work you can and you can't give
a hundred percent to your health and
fitness you can yeah and you can't give
it 100 to jiu jitsu yeah
you can only give you only have 100 yeah
so you got to be careful yeah and and
pay attention to what you're gonna leave
on the table Yeah that's what you got to
do that's the way it is you're only
going to get trade-offs not a solution
doesn't exist yeah so really by its own
nature you you essentially if if you can
cut that down
the more you cut that down the better
off you're going to be the less things
you you need yeah like you know less
less moving parts or whatever less Parts
taking you know taking away from the
other
but when you think about and especially
if you take this this element this
element of Life seriously which element
this like the trailer it's always the
trade-off yeah you know got it man you
could
you could trim away a lot of BS in your
life definitely do that because you're
probably
spending time doing stuff that literally
you actually not only is it stuff that
you don't really care about it's not
that you actually know is bad right yeah
I mean stuff that you legitimately know
is not beneficial to you it's not
helping your family it's not helping
your work it's not helping your
Jiu-Jitsu it's not helping your health
and fitness there you are doing it
you're trading it off
it's it's a bad move so that's another
good point you got to pay attention not
to just the things you want but what are
you investing in that you don't even
want at all and you're investing into it
that's sad yeah and that's a big price
too right because you know how the whole
thing I mean this is kind of a
it's not a cliche because it's so so so
true where you you probably spend some
money on the on the BS stuff for sure
you do but you spend time on it like you
know the kind where you're well here's
the thing though
what is money
it is time yeah you've traded your time
for some money at some point now you're
just using that money to spend somewhere
else yeah yeah time is the ultimate
thing right yeah that every month all
the money that you have you you had to
invest time into yeah
that's weird I mean which is another
good reason why you want to set your
life up so that you so that your your
money is coming in when it doesn't take
a bunch of time investment that's the
goal right yeah that's the goal that's
what you want to get toward but you have
to invest a lot of time up front to get
to a point where you don't have to
invest time
continuously in order to get an income
from it
so what's your list you'd say I would I
would say knowing you obviously your
family for for
working out at four in the freaking
morning or whatever yeah it's the same
it's probably the same yeah work right
all the different work all these
different businesses
you know family obviously Health
obviously Jiu Jitsu obviously and then
it's just like oh guitar it's you know
surfing yeah all that good stuff so
yeah you know and for me the lopsided
back it was just lopsided because it was
just teams yeah yeah the teams were
massive yeah and everything else
combined kind of like equaled the teams
yeah and see and that's a good point too
where because in that moment in that at
that point in your life or whatever it's
kind of like
that kind of was who you are where
whatever you know especially and you
weren't
you weren't married right I'm not
married I got married yeah but there was
a music in the teams and you were not
married okay so you're just hundred
percent maybe seal 100 yeah yeah no
work-life balance but I'll tell you even
when I got married it wasn't it was
still a large percentage Yeah luckily my
wife was awesome you know and she kind
of knew what she was getting into I told
her what she was getting into on our way
to get married
right Hey listen you're a BINA
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the the Jocko underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we
you mobilized
Underground